breaking news this morning the cdc and
the fda
have just issued a joint statement
recommending a pause
in the use of the johnson and johnson
vaccine in the u.s
the agencies say they are reviewing six
reported cases
of a rare type of blood clot in people
who have received the vaccine
nearly seven million doses of the j j
vaccine have already been administered
in the u.s
officials say these adverse offense
events appear to be extremely rare
the fda will hold a press conference at
10 a.m eastern with more information in
just a few minutes
we're going to talk to dr david agus to
find out what's going on exactly but
this is this is a big surprise here i
mean these all six recipients
uh who have the blood cut were women
between the ages of 18 and 48. one woman
died and a second woman
in nebraska has been hospitalized in
critical condition very concerning and
even if it comes back online and they
say everything's fine
for some people who are already
skeptical this is going to stick in
their mind that doesn't help
and there are 9 million additional
doshas that have been shipped out to
the states so